i was under the impression like someone
had to tell you like no dude you were on
this show malcolm in the middle of the
big show and you're like how you
described it to me that's how i always
thought it was and you'd be watching the
episodes
i'll say this this is that's
the first time that i've actually ever
gotten to clarify
so i remember from uh you know like
when you were younger doing malcolm in
the middle like you were like the kid
with the obnoxiously flashy cars yeah
that was kind of your deal and and i
think at the time you were like maybe
like
barely legal age to drive yeah and you
had these crazy cars and and i i got a
kick out of that man yeah and crazy
getting ready to speak to you today and
seeing that you're now 35 years old yeah
i know it's over it's everybody like
it's over i mean i just think of you as
like yeah because everybody does things
yeah you know
yes so going back
cars were definitely my vice you know
what i mean like i've always liked cars
obviously i went into racing and all
that but like even before that i just
loved cool cars i love driving
um but yeah now
35 you know i look back and i think of
my life 20 years ago and i go
was that i really was that me like
that that was pretty cool you know what
i mean so right you know now i i uh you
know i have an eight-month-old son and a
wife and i drive a mitsubishi
well i had to get like a car for for the
baby
paul here was saying
that he read something or saw something
that uh that you
have suffered a bunch of concussions
which make uh
make it difficult for you to remember
like the years of malcolm in the middle
yeah
you know it's it's an interesting
i i've
i've thought about it a lot like over my
years of like you know
why do i have a bad memory you know what
i mean the only logical thing i can say
is yeah i've had nine concussions you
know what i mean like i've and they're
all from cars no when i was a kid
playing basketball and getting tripped i
played football you know like pee wee
football like just doing
life things sports and you know uh there
were some in in car car like racing
accidents but you know for the most part
no like it's not just that but and i i
try i've gone to a lot of doctors over
it and uh
looked into it and
i don't know as weird as it sounds
i don't want to blame the concussions or
blame anything else i just think it's
the fact that i did so [ __ ] much
okay when in that time frame that of
course i can't remember all of it you
know what i mean okay you know do you
remember you have some memory of
memories you know like like there's
there's definitely things that pop up
and i go like whoa but a lot of it
of my memories now are almost like i
can't distinguish if it was a dream or
if it was reality yeah you know what i
mean like thing places i went things
like you know people i hung out whatever
it was you know what i mean i heard
something also that really do that i
heard something also that you've had
like these mini strokes throughout your
life yeah is that related to the
concussion is that a separate thing
this is why maybe without getting into
it like i i never trust doctors anymore
the rest of my life um i went for a long
time i was having these uh
these episodes uh
where
i'd have like numbness and i couldn't
really see like i lose peripheral vision
and all this stuff and everyone was
telling me like you're having tias
transient ischemic attacks or mini
strokes i'm like what like what are you
talking about like i'm healthy like i
don't do or you know i don't have any of
the the
the signs of people who would normally
have those things so like it didn't make
sense so i went to a bunch of doctors
and nobody could really give me like a
straight up answer so i had people kind
of speculating
and of course like i said what they were
speculating and now it turns out
literally after all that and like if you
search my name like all it talks about
is how like i have no memory or i'm
dying on strokes
and all this kind of stuff
and the reality is like i finally got
diagnosed with or migraines
so just intense
intense migraines that literally like
those are the symptoms and it it's
similar symptoms to transit ischemic
attacks okay now all this time like i've
been being told that and thinking that
we're realistically like i just had some
pretty intense migraines got you but the
story's out there is
like you searched my name it's basically
he's dying right it's life
he doesn't know where he is
and it's funny because like i i've never
talked about it i did dancing with the
stars
four years ago now wow we've had a lot
of guests that have done dances yeah i
did dancing with the stars did you have
fun did you enjoy it i did not enjoy it
i loved it
i can't blame the show and and like
after my season i went back and you know
i was a friend of the show and i would
go to like the following sequence
seasons and sit in the audience and
stuff it was just like uncomfortable for
me man i was i was newly sober and i was
like just like in a really awkward phase
of my life and it's an awkward thing to
do yeah you know well how'd you do on
the show i did pretty good i made it to
the finale wow so it's top two top three
top three
and uh i
i was a nervous wreck every single time
i had to go out like i was a disaster
because like i'm a little neurotic like
i wanna be
not perfect but like i wanna do my best
you know what i mean and i put a lot of
pressure on myself but that's like that
competitive
like
sure nature in me that i just wanna i
wanna be the best i can be so like i
would i would be in rehearsal like 12
hours a day like longer than anybody i
think i broke the record for most
rehearsing in a season but that's just
the way 12 hours a day if not more geez
that was like in the studio like then i
go home and like practice too because
i'm just i'm i'm a fool wow were you
like that with like rehearsing lines and
stuff always and [ __ ] like that
that was always easy for me like i would
look at it once or twice before i went
to bed and like i'd wake up in the
morning and somehow i just know it you
know so that was never like a thing but
i'm not a dancer you know right right at
all
and you know they've been asking me to
do the show for like 12 years like all
seasons i was like no hell no i don't
dance like it's not my personality like
i'm right even though i'm in uh the
entertainment business i'm pretty shy i
think you know what i mean like i'm not
like i don't want to be seen you know to
me i'm more like i'll be over here sure
give me my lines i'll say my lines and
i'll go back to my trailer you know what
i mean like i'm not
hollywood or whatever you want right
but i did it and i'll say the first
episode the first like time i went on
stage
it was one of the coolest feelings i've
ever felt like hearing like the crowd go
crazy like when i when i know i and i
killed it so i was really excited so i
enjoyed it but anyway i was bringing
that up because i was talking about
that's kind of where the story came from
of my memory
from their little story line on the show
yeah because they have they have
um an episode like most memorable year
and to be honest like i love dancing
with the stars and i don't want to like
say anything that'll make them hate me
but they kind of tell you what your most
memorable year is going to be you know
what i mean and they were like it's 2001
because it's when you were nominated for
an emmy and the golden globes and all
that kind of stuff and they're like we
want you to talk all about it and i go
i don't remember what i felt that like i
don't you know and so it was me kind of
blowing off the fact that like i can't
say that's my favorite year because like
i can't tell you what happened in 2001
you know i mean you would have to tell
me what happened in 2001 like frankie
muniz can't even remember but they
didn't they didn't really say it just
kind of like the storyline in my episode
then was like you know i
as cheesy as it is i said my most
memorable year is like is the present
because i've learned through all my past
to live in the moment like accept
everything for what it is whatever right
and i brought up like the fact that like
i don't
i had to say like i don't really
remember
but i wasn't saying i don't remember
anything i was
right just saying
told me what i ate for breakfast the day
that i went to the when i was down here
fernandez i go i have no idea right i
mean like
that's so funny i was under the
impression like someone had to tell you
like no dude you were on this show
malcolm in the middle of a big show
you're like described it to me that's
how i always thought it was and you'd be
watching the episode like
i'll say this this is that's right this
is the first time that i've actually
ever gotten to clarify oh well great
we're going to cut this clip out and
we'll send it out dude
you're going to cut this clip out and
it's this
no no we'll we'll promote this dude this
is a big deal well it's it's just funny
cause like
you know i have people write me all the
time like oh it's so sad that you don't
i'm like
[Applause]
my wife he just met she
i am afraid
to forget memories now as you know what
i mean like because like or good moments
like i wanted
so she
has journaled like our entire
relationship you know what i mean why
because she thinks you're gonna forget
it ask him
i might need it
you know i i just like to be able to go
back because when i read it on paper it
brings me back to that to that moment
completely you know what i mean and even
now having a son like he's eight months
old and i go like how is he eight months
old you know because i i remember him
how he is right now it's not that i
don't remember but i see him right now i
can't remember
just like any other normal person
journals yeah
yeah because i have a problem with my
memory too but like i also read that
like smart people do that because they
have so much bandwidth going in that
they don't they purposely just let it go
out because if they retain it all
they're going to lose their [ __ ] mind
i think that is i mean i'm definitely
smart so
no i i think that's more of it to be
honest like is
especially if you think i started acting
when i was eight
malcolm when i was 12 to 20. you know
like i was literally every moment of my
life from when i started acting until i
stopped i had to be somewhere and had to
do something yeah you know what i mean
so there becomes a point i think where
you just kind of start
just in one ear as the other floating
but you just kind of you do what you got
to do when you go where you need to go
and and you do your best job but then
you forget it well it's crazy because
like you know i i i found that i had
this problem and then i'd go to steve
i'm like dude i can't remember it and
steve can remember the month in the year
to a t but like his third grade teacher
said to him line by line and i'm like
what the [ __ ] yeah your money is crazy i
generally have a really good memory yeah
particularly for dates and stuff like
that however i totally relate to what
you were saying about you know so much
stuff happened like for example if if i
were to sit down and watch an episode of
my old show wild boys yes which we taped
all over the world from 2003 to 2005
yeah i
i'm sure that a bunch of the scenes that
were i have no recollection
i did that yeah i did that like i should
remember wait you you wouldn't
i would absolutely not like i would i
would i would feel like i was watching a
bunch of that stuff for the same time
and and it's specifically because what
frankie said just so much happened right
yeah so there was just so much going on
all the time so yeah but wow
i i got to watch i never watched malcolm
you know when it was on you just you
kind of film it but now with like the
streaming services like you can sit down
and just kind of crank through and my
wife had never seen it so we watched it
a few years ago and i truly could watch
it as
like a fan
because i i really didn't know what was
going to happen
i could watch it as a fan because i'm
[ __ ] awesome
i don't see it as me i'm saying like you
know you're from an outsider's
perspective
but also because when you film i filmed
the parts i was in i don't really know
what else they filmed in the show i mean
like i don't know how that turned out or
the other you wouldn't watch it when it
aired
no like a viewing party with your buds
oh no no
i was always kind of more like
embarrassed to like i don't know just
kind of awkward yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]